[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's endlich mal wieder ein wort
rezept also ein rezept aus einem topf
ohne wirklich nur ganz wenig
kochgeschirr braucht und dieses ist ein
rezept für murat denn ich habe ein super
kubot mit spaghetti mit bisschen
tierische zutaten sag ich mal also mit
spitz paprika und das ist wirklich eine
super würzige mischung auch richtig
lecker herzhaft und ich zeige euch jetzt
mal die wenigen zutaten dann geht auch
gleich los für das gericht brauche ich
400 gramm spaghetti 200 gramm
cocktailtomaten eine zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen fünf esslöffel olivenöl
einen esslöffel getrockneter minze und
oregano etwas paprika mag ich habe ich
pfeffer und einen würfel zucker einen
esslöffel balsamico creme ein paar
oliven hier habe ich noch vier
paprikaschoten eine chilischote etwas
zurück und 800 bis 900 milliliter wasser
landgerichtes sind ja genial meinte
wirklich so vereinfacht sind und ich
gleich alles in einen topf reinschmeißen
kann
jetzt nehme ich einfach nur die cocktail
tomaten und halte sie und das restliche
gemüse also die zwiebeln und die
knoblauchzehen die werden fein gewürfelt
die oliven weil ich natürlich noch
entkernen und klein schneiden und dann
ist die paprikaschote und die
chilischote dran
die kann ich auch ganz grob zerkleinern
und dies tut muss einfach in scheiben
schneiden
[Musik]
und sobald alle zutaten geschnitten sind
ist die meiste arbeit schon erledigt
denn jetzt kann man alle zutaten einfach
in einen großen topf und dann kann alles
zusammen garen von port eben morata
sagst du als feature experte dazu soll
die schöffin manches ist ein türkischer
knoblauch es ist ein guter markt und
farbstoffen ich esse ich eigentlich
nicht so gern ja wir sagen dir zuliebe
ja dies eigentlich gesund aber ich würde
sagen auch veganer muss man sterben
deswegen esse ich wusste dass ich
wirklich gerne dass meine kindheit
gegessen und ist natürlich die
frühkindlichen geschmacksträger
also ich denke dass er gestern auf
verzichten muss ich ehrlich sagen okay
ab und zu geht's ja man beschwingt
wirklich lecker morgens mittags abends
martin structure und die dies für
schritt kommt dass ich los oder in
typischen zuckermarkt überall an ihre
ecke und wohl die mit der gelben
verpackung ich sagen aber ich sag nur
die verpackung die ist nicht wirklich
die beste aber ist dass ich auch
geschmackssache natürlich auf jeden fall
jetzt habe ich alle zutaten drin ein
bisschen salz gebe ich dazu aber da
musst du aufpassen denn das produkt hat
wirklich ist zeigt gut gewürzt und dann
kommt jetzt das wasser mit rein da lasse
ich jetzt einfach mal so 100 bis 200
milliliter übrig und kann jetzt die
zutaten im topf aufkochen lassen und
dann schalte ich die hitze runter auf
mittlere stufe
und dann braucht so etwa 15 minuten also
je nach model sorte im islam
zwischendurch einfach mal rühren und
probieren und wenn ihr dann noch wasser
benötigt dann noch zu fügen und dann
sind wir schon fertig jetzt kann man
zusammen abspülen und saubermachen
tischdecken wieder zusammen oder du hast
alleine bis gleich
[Musik]
jetzt ist das essen fertig und es riecht
richtig lecker hier im haus aber muras
mein coach denis leider nicht da das ist
natürlich wieder typische morath essen
ist fertig und der mann und verschwinden
wird
männer jetzt müsst ihr einfach probieren
ok ob dann auch mit ihr euch aber klar
doch so kam ich mache ich meine passion
und dürft ihr probieren aber hier im
haus riecht echt super lecker und ich
muss sagen ich es nicht so ganz gerne
zurück weil es mir echt manchmal zu
würzig ist aber da drin denke hier ist
wirklich genial
ich glaube ich besser jetzt freue ich
mich aufs mittagessen samira schmeckt es
auch gut vielleicht ohne chili dann aber
heute wäre freundin und mega lecker echt
super witzig hermann dadurch noch gut
lecker sehr gut wir freuen uns jetzt
auch alle auf dieses rezept und wenn ihr
das gerne umgestalten möchte wenn ihr
sagt ich mache kein chili oder keine
peperoni keine oliven dann nehmt einfach
was anderes was ihr zu hause habt
monfort gerichtet sind immer die
perfekte resteverwertung auch und das
zuzog hatte ich übrigens im gefrierfach
denn murat kauft immer im ganzen vorjahr
das reicht um so für 20 familien und 20
monate und dann friere ich das immer
einen einzelnen in kleinen tütchen und
kann es dann einfach bei bedarf auftaut
und verwenden
das rezept findet ihr komplett noch mal
auf meinem blog auf cds - blog.de ich
wünsche euch einen guten appetit und uns
natürlich auch einen guten appetit und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
fließt dann tschüss und jetzt gibt es
nicht
[Musik]